hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the curse of
black water now I've been waiting for a
pirate-themed horror game for the
longest time and I'm so excited to
finally be able to it's not about
pirates what all right guys it's not
about pirates okay it's about something
else I don't know but it's not pirates
bloody Wow alright whatever let's get
into the game new story regular let's
see what it's all about
I'm actually pretty excited about this
because it's made by the same guy that
made the Slenderman shadow maps of which
I've played numerous times mark Steen is
the guy's name if you don't know he play
he made carnival the Christmas map
sanatorium prison all those good ones in
cooperation with Raber gasps I think
that's the same guy he was working with
before if I'm not mistaken the curse
wasn't there a show a long time ago
called like the Pirates of Blackwater
that was great show is a cartoon a long
time ago I never finished it I don't
think it ever finished anyway the forest
premonitions so he asked how's death
hard she said it just keeps going that
is what she said isn't it okay no turns
diva chasin and I'm a paranormal
investigator okay I make a living out of
scaring other people with made-up
stories and ghosts poltergeists of the
supernatural
okay of course I've never seen these
spirits nor do I believe in such things
that was until I visited Blackwater
Maternity Hospital oh it was operational
in 1940's until a plague struck
Maternity Hospital those lives are those
are dumped it's sort of my journey
towards Blackwater are there gonna be
creepy little kids in this game cuz I
don't do well with creepy little kids
damn it
dad such potential the curse of
Blackwater does not not sound like a
pirate horror game and wouldn't a pirate
horror game sound like an amazing horror
game okay anyway enough I take that gig
ghost stabs dead okay no I collect the
items off the table well it's awfully
glarry but I'll try my best
got medicine anything else I can pick up
there do not look like it I don't need
no map
follow the path why couldn't I have
followed with my car oh yeah it wouldn't
have been as spooky okay so this game is
made on the Unity engine I've got G and
H batteries which look like car
batteries if I wasn't mistaken but I
guess this must be some heavy-duty lamp
that actually has proper throw which is
very nice it actually looks like I'm
carrying a lamp in the middle of the
night so thank you Mark Steen for making
a proper lamp okay we got a lamp post
here some sort of landmark looking for a
hospital filled with babies most likely
dead babies ghosts babies mamas crows
apparently I like the way the whole
foliage moves when I turn my camera
that's very very nice to know that the
leaves are all sprites hmm not the drink
wide my lamp flicker it's some there in
the darkness does something one them
[Music]
okay so there just happened to be 10,000
birds in that one Bush a burden hands
worth 10,000 in the bush all right all
right all right let's go still don't
know why I needed to abandon my car so
far away from my destination but it must
be because I have such powerful okay
no thank you okay most people because I
have such powerful legs and M total what
was that I heard something I keep
talking and things happen don't flick
around on this little lamp II don't
flick around on me I got stuff to do I
got places to be can i sprint I could
have sprinted a long time ago why do I
never ever ever ever that just go up who
cares why did I never ever ever ever try
the sprint right off the bat I need to
start doing that because it's becoming
problematic for me still following the
lampposts this reminds me a lot that go
out too oh no that was just my lamp
this reminds me a lot of the
introduction to slender the arrival
except it's starting out much darker you
know I read them blog
okay I hear some there's some in those
words and all the lamps are out now why
now why would they go out now my lantern
doesn't seem to have as much oomph as it
used to
it's flickering a bit more doesn't throw
as far I'm hearing strange noises I got
my volume turned way up as per use so
I'm hearing even the tiniest
discrepancies something's happening
where the hell is this place I've been
wandering for about five minutes okay
I'm okay I think I think I'm okay I
think I'm okay no need to panic no need
to panic we're okay
Marc's team definitely stepped up his
game here very well done
I'm gonna assume that this is nothing
like a slender game eternal science the
cries of souls decades lost check out
throughout the building expressing their
endless grief in the only way they knew
by going
okay all right now then I'm actually
inside the building I can cease with
this [ __ ] miss fourth of September
entry 1 the influx of new patients is
indeed worrying and is straining our
resources someone the risk of a
contagious infection occurring is
increasing by the day dr. Stevens did
note however that mortalities would
indeed provide us with more biological
tissue to conduct experiments with a
research program is decades ahead of
other institutions and soon the whole of
humanity will benefit knowing that puts
my mind at ease our work is not for the
faint of heart well now this is in a
maternity hospital and I'm assuming that
you probably shouldn't leave notes like
that right on the front desk Oh reminds
me of sanatorium just a little bit hello
door is locked ok this one too door is
locked ok so I need to wander these
halls perfectly normal halls by the way
totally not creepy and find me some keys
that does sound familiar
hello man the ambiance is definitely
pumping it of maximum if ffice carroty
and force carroty that's a term that i
just made up that scares per second
heart beats per minute I don't know
whatever whatever you want to call me
it's really cool but it is really hang
on if I put another there we go okay I
knew my flashlight wasn't as lively as
it was before death really really death
you don't need to be so melodramatic you
done room I don't think there was
anything actually in those drawers
before because my hand didn't turn into
anything else and yes it's perfectly
normal for your hand it just suddenly
[ __ ]
okay all right
hello Oh nope something about having
that just sectioned off like that
maximum maximizes the nope ability of
that situation okay it's fine nothing to
worry about I'm just scaring myself
which is what horror games are supposed
to make you do like so far this is an
example of a great horror game because I
haven't seen a monster yet and yet I'm
still scared it's very very well done
mark Steen did a good job so far
but I will reserve judgment until later
because he could still [ __ ] it up ass so
to speak well he's already got a mark in
my book a black mark from not making
this oh they're jiggly ill
eyes alrighty then okie dokie moving on
moving forward no problemo just a little
jump scare from the closet filled with
body parts that's better than the one in
I amnesia that had a sting full of
skulls that was barely startling hisao
is just weird body parts why why was
there a clause aha no escape Oh show you
cuz I'm going to the sleep ward and
there's nothing you can do to stop me
seriously what's with these weird
windows they're just gaps into the inner
walls I don't know I don't care I need
to find ok no body parts tumbling out of
that one well oh got a battery sweet I
need those because apparently I'm gonna
be using a lot of them I don't know if
the game just artificially made my lamp
there it starts to go okay now it's
gonna start fading I'll try to hold off
as long as possible
oh don't let go dividers
nothing nothing nothing uh I don't know
if I'm actually supposed to find
anything else I've already found a key
but I'm just gonna go through everything
anyway just because I can and I need to
find batteries and diapers for when I
crap my pants no nope nope I don't know
what anything else in this place is they
look like bullets and I don't think
there's anything you can shoot at in
here slightly disconcerting but that's
okay also the windows are boarded up
that's a good sign that's always a good
sign in a horror game I don't know if
they were trying to keep something out
and trying to keep something in not yet
still got juice
still got hang on a second still got
plenty of juice Jamba Juice okay nothing
all right all right all right all right
let's go nope nothing okay I'm assuming
that the one key is not the only key
here because I there were two locked
doors and I'm assuming I'm gonna find a
couple more when I get to the other side
here this may take some time I'm ready
for a bunch of body parts to start
tumbling out of anywhere who knows when
that'll happen again don't there we go
another battery okay I'm only finding
more batteries but that's not a bad
thing okay all right that's much better
hang on I'm gonna get Hannah I want to
see before I go in and sleep ward okay
there's places upstairs I think this is
a sleep board because I saw those baby
cribs yeah all right let's go upstairs
let's go all right I'm ready ready to
face what other diabolical demon haunts
these hallways sir same mechanic that's
nice a mechanic I hope I hope it
auto-saves dammit well what the hell
whoa what the hell there's a lot of
locked doors around here huh
door locked door lock there wasn't one
on this side was there no there's a lot
of locked doors what's with all the
locking miss miss aha there we go no
well did I just summon it some somebody
I've done bad I remember in the witch's
house when I turned on the music box it
didn't end so it didn't end so wah ha
that's what I was trying to say what's
with all the blocks and the chairs
weren't these babies and lose the sleep
room what's going on hop on take it for
a ride ride it my pony saddle
[Music]
okay I'm beginning to think that's
actually a monster wandering the halls
objective completed 28th of September
entry to locate the hidden research labs
teleportation no not actually something
there there is something there that is a
thing nada that is the thing that is the
thing hangout ago read this
teleportation seismic fragile Rooster's
science fast fact achieving this would
meet a great accomplish for him and
anybody come home multiple years I have
these almonds I'm feasible there is
something there there is you can't tell
me there's not you can't tell you it's
not you can't fool me
I just got it okay alright final I'll
man up and see what it is okay okay good
I saw something was it what are you I
say
oh come on okay Oh time I was hoping
there would be some objective after my
or save point after my this is well done
its well then good job good job it's not
pirates it's just as good I guess so I
do I um excuse me pardon me I'm fine
thank you thank you all so much for
watching hopefully more parts will be
coming out soon I'll start where I left
off last time after I complete that
objective I don't know why I don't know
how this same mechanic works so if you
guys want to fill me in on the comments
below I will take that into
consideration on when I play further so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for video said I've done
if you want to play the game for
yourself it's not free unfortunately but
it's not very expensive you can check
the link in the description below so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more video I said
that already alright stay in the next
video
but faster holding up grandpa